this is the moment former prime minister
Imran Khan was shot in the leg
chaos broke out after the leader of
Pakistan tarike and South party was
attacked
may God protect Imran Khan by the grace
of God we are okay some of our
compatriots are wounded and one has been
killed please keep us all in your
prayers
other party leaders were also wounded
police arrested the gunman who's
reportedly confessed to the attack he
said he wanted to stop Han from quote
misleading people with some politicians
demanding Revenge the party's leadership
called for calm we're all organizing
shortly in each city in Pakistan that we
find ourselves in as a mark of our
protest we do not intend to attack
anyone we don't intend to allow anyone
to attack us either but that's a story
for later
Imran Khan was leading a slow-moving
March to the capital Islamabad from the
city of Lahore about 350 kilometers to
the South
the Convoy hoped to force the government
to give a power since losing the
Premiership through a new confidence
Court in April Khan has insisted he will
not stop campaigning until early
elections are held the attack is likely
to further fuel political unrest some
members of Imran Khan's own party have
been on the record uh calling it to
bloody March and expressing the
apprehension that the March could get
bloody and could get uh you know out of
control Imran Khan is out of danger and
without providing any proof his party
Secretary General says Han told him to
name the alleged attackers
I have no doubt three people involved in
this RPM Shabbat Sharif interior
Minister Rana sanala and Major General
Faisal our demand is all three be
removed from their posts and if they're
not removed then there'll be
Country-Wide protests
protests have already broken out in
several cities the Prime Minister has
called for an investigation and
condemned the violence all political
leaders including those who oppose Imran
Khan have reiterated the condemnation
but that's unlikely to bring down
political temperature as Pakistan enters
another phase of instability
let's hear the latest now from Kamal
Haider who's in Islamabad hello there
Kamal what more could you tell us about
a statement released by Khan from
hospital
well Khan did release that statement
blaming the three people that Osama bin
jawed mentioned in that report and he
said that there will be more protests if
these people are not sacked now it is
interesting also to note that there is
protests taking place across the country
we have also just been told that tear
gas shells were used against protesters
in islamabads between Raul Pindi and
Islamabad that says about Square this is
an important intersection that leads to
Islamabad there are also serious
concerns being raised about the
circumstances because what we have been
able to see from that footage is a
volley of automatic gunfire which
according to senior advisors of the
Imran Khan party came from a Kalashnikov
and also the arrest of that what the
government said was a lone wolf acting
on his own with a handgun of perhaps
this was a diversionary tactics those
questions are being raised by seniors
journalists across Pakistan Imran Khan
on the other hand has appealed to the
protesters to remain peaceful saying
that the enemies of Pakistan want to
show chaos in this country and that
people should not take matters into
their own hands however there is
considerable anger and that anger has
spilled over onto the streets in major
cities across the country in Pakistan
and of course this would leave to lead
to more political instability and the
political temperatures rise now Imran
Khan was due to address the rally before
those shorts were fired by the Assassin
and of course he was going to reveal
other details which he said he would be
revealing about the State of Affairs and
particularly the government now it is
also important to note that although the
protests have broken out across the
country and Imran Khan one is injured
his party workers are saying that they
will continue this much Imran Khan has
insisted he talked to Al Jazeera a few
days ago we were on the container with
him and he told us that there were
serious threats to his life and he knew
that in case there was an attack on him
that he knew who the culprits would be
all right plenty of moving parts to the
story we appreciate the update Kamal
Haider live for us in Islamabad